hey caitlin hey evan you know what they
say about making
assumptions what do they say it makes a
booty out of you and me but i have an
assumption to make about this podcast
topic about assumptions
okay it's gonna be a great podcast
[Music]
hi guys welcome back to the evan caitlin
podcast today we're going to be talking
about your assumptions about our work
which is basically
our entire lives so we're sticking with
that intro
it wasn't good it was okay
i thought so long and hard about it what
was your intro
oh it doesn't it doesn't work now it
doesn't work also what were you giggling
about right before we started vodka they
were wearing the same t-shirt
that was actually what my intro was
going to be about
we don't plan this you guys we just have
a lot of the same shirts
we wear 90 merch so today we're going to
be tackling assumptions about
um our day jobs which is making content
and
by day jobs we mean like our seven days
a week
all day jobs yeah until we go to bed
now we started out just doing youtube
videos and
posting occasionally on social media but
it's expanded over the years it's
so strange saying years and it literally
being like
three years three and a half ish three
and a half ish years grown from
just a single youtube channel to five
active
youtube channels now now that we have
the the evan caitlin ii up and running
that's that's true and three distinct
branches
of content and with the gaming we have
the
twitch and youtube side there's a lot
going on now a lot of
a lot of juggling going on these days
yeah yeah
it is it is a lot i think most of the
assumptions are mostly about youtube
yeah um i read through these uh
if if you're just now hopping in this is
the third installment of our assumptions
about us but we got these a bit ago so
it's even been a while since i read them
so it'll be a slight surprise for both
of us yeah so we did assumptions
about us generically assumptions about
our relationship and now it's
assumptions about words
but before we do that should we move on
to a little what's new segment
yeah we haven't done that in a while
what's new with you is there a music
that we play here
i don't think so
well i think that what's new are we
going to talk about how our merch got
stolen
or like oh no how we are streaming more
okay
we're going to do that i mean you can't
mention that march getting stolen and
then not talk about it we don't want to
focus on the negative
and like well i guess like there is one
positive hey if
our merch is getting stolen does that
mean that we've made it as youtubers i
think that means we've made it
i mean it's not a big story one of our
um
is one of our twitch mods oh yeah let us
know
um that he found a version of our make
fail make shirt um on some i don't
even remember what website but they're
selling our make fail make
yeah and like if people are searching
for that and they order from the
not right website go to shop evan and
katelyn.com for real merch
but um if they order from that website
thinking that they're buying our merch
and it gets
in and there's no customer service or if
it's bad quality i do understand
why it's a worry for a lot of youtubers
yeah
yeah you don't want to like
misrepresenting but anyways
but anyways uh the other thing that
we've been doing is we have been
streaming a lot in a lot of new ways we
we started our very first like inaugural
like departure from
gaming twitch streams with our
underwater stream and that was a that
was an experience we have that video
probably still coming out on the 31st of
this month
hopefully hopefully hopefully fingers
crossed but um
and you'll hear more of why it's
hopefully in the after show if you guys
are patrons
but i don't know if we go into the why
it's hopefully
you'll hear a lot more about the behind
the scenes of
doing the um underwater stream
in the patreon after show yeah but after
that i kind of got really excited about
doing
non-typical streams and the first thing
that i did is i built a mobile streaming
setup
and and that's all like kind of working
now although i haven't done a
test stream with version 2.0 then we
also did a garage stream
and it's been fun like thinking about
they're both technically garage streams
oh yeah wait so it's it's it's more like
there's the mobile stream and then there
is a
um uh what's the right word not stagnant
like with the opposite of mobile uh
stationary stationary
yeah garage stream and the reason that
there's two
the mobile is literally we can just like
get up and walk around with it
yeah and i tested it um i can combine i
can like
cross thread the internet from my
phone's hotspot and another hotspot
and that creates an internet speed
that's fast enough to stream
fairly high quality enough so we could
like go out into the woods
find a scary forest and do a night
stream
it's funny you've been you've been
bringing that up lately specifically
like oh is there like a scary forest we
can go stream in
and i'm like who are you me yes
[Laughter]
i i just also know that you would have a
lot of fun with that oh my gosh i would
but like we need to do it safely and we
need to set a good
like we need woods that we can be in at
night
we need to be good role models we need
to be good role models but
it would be really nice to go out and do
a scary livestream
yeah do you want the voice yeah
yeah no you don't you need the device
i'm scared i'm a scary lady
i'm a scary little lady here i got i'll
i'll
deepen it even more for you try it again
i'm scared
happening no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
you stop that um but the reason that
there's
also a a
like stationary garage stream is because
it allows us to have three different
cameras which we can't do let me tell
you we have two cameras in the um
yeah mobile stream but anyways we've
been experimenting a lot it's been fun
we've done a couple streams they're up
on the second channel yeah but it's
it's a new challenge just like i feel
like we keep on like figuring
one level of something out and then we
up up it and then up it and up it and up
it
and at each of these levels i mean the
the garage stream
we need to kind of figure out what
project can we do
fully in a live stream what makes a cool
visual difference what doesn't make
too much noise and how do we balance
like the project versus the interaction
and all of that it's it's a lot
thinking sorry guys there's a lot to
figure out but like it's
it's nice having these challenges
and then figuring out how to overcome
them thinking about um
like what projects we can do in like a
two to three hour session that we can
start and
finish makes me think that i i wonder
if people like i wonder how long people
assume our projects take
because i mean sometimes we'll include a
one sleep later which is
the shirt we're both wearing right now
shop evan and katelyn.com um
sometimes we'll include like a one sleep
later or two sleeps later or after
several hours
yeah but we don't put that for for every
day that goes by there's a lot more days
that go by that actually
than what actually gets acknowledged in
the edit and even if you try to like
count what outfits we're in sometimes
we'll like put on the same
shirt for continuity or something well
often like and then
we can explain why um we edit as we go
so caitlyn can figure out
what like how the
the video is shaping up do we need more
talking do we need more montage or
you know like let's figure out the pace
of it so that we like we don't film
everything and then i have to cut it all
out later
so sometimes like we'll film just like
an hour
and that'll be enough for caitlyn to
edit for the rest of the day and then i
even have like a special
area in my closet to re-hang the shirt
that i'm wearing
in our most recent video and i'll admit
i've worn like the same shirt for
multiple multiple days in a row
i'm in the same pj pants i've been in
for like a week
at least but they don't stink as much as
my shirts too
oh yeah should we um yeah let's just
jump into like we're already talking
about work unless there's somebody
some assumptions that's my segue all
right let's do it okay
um so we have an assumption
from saber fish i assume that evan was
the one that got caitlyn into making
things
specifically with resin i think that
i i'm generally the person that leads
the charge
with some projects because
caitlyn again is editing which is
honestly one of the hardest things that
we do like
making a video is like entertaining
is is difficult and anyone who's
tried to make a video entertaining i
think this is taking like a step back
though
this isn't like for any individual
project
who who was the first person that
recommended resin
i i can't really remember really the
ideation is
pretty much equally both of us i think
so here's my memory of it okay yeah go
for it i think the resin was me
because what was our first resin project
geode the
geode table and my idea was everyone was
doing river tables
i bet we could do a geode table we never
tackled any resin before that
so i think the resin was me i think
there have been a lot of forms of making
that are 100 you like i mean anything
that's digital fabrication
cnc um 3d printing
i think a lot of the water stream yeah
the underwater stream things that
involve
like pressurized systems like the um
propane cannon or the underwater stream
or the uh
shooting each other with air cannon
those are all 100
you i would say with like
i think in the beginning like very very
beginning
i think i i had like an
itch to like
make diy things like for our house and
for our wedding because i was cheap
but i so i think i had like the itch to
to do it
maybe before you did but i think you
took more of the initiative
i had like the want to do it but you
took more of the initiative
to actually do it yeah
i think that makes sense you know that
that rings true to me yeah that's like
how i'm remembering it
yeah so for the making it kind of just
depended on like what was the thing
yeah but in terms of the ideation it
really is equally both of us and
sometimes what's pretty funny is on the
the crazier end of projects caitlyn like
i'm the one who like
makes a call on whether it's doable or
not sometimes caitlyn comes to me like
it's shark week she's like okay
evan shark i have this crazy idiot let's
do this crazy thing
and i like either like approve it as
something that's like achievable within
our means or i say
yeah like you know sometimes we'll still
write it down as like you know maybe
this will spark something else like we
like maybe
if we have time yeah there are some
projects that we
we want to do that would be cool but
that are just sometimes literally too
big
too heavy would take too long i can see
that we're thinking about the same ones
we're thinking about the same one yeah
so we have an anime nerd alert i assume
that evan was the one who first started
putting googly eyes on the tools
you are correct yeah yeah i'm pretty
sure that was you and you bought the
giant pack of googly eyes on amazon
and i bought like the giant six inch
googly eyes for the um for the ac
and for the ac i'm so glad i did that i
i love his i honestly feel like i need
to get more googly eyes going again
i feel like we need to find more big
things to put the googly eyes yeah
okay i'm down for it challenge accepted
yeah um from maybe music i assume that
you guys are actually professionals you
know how to use a mic
pack and the cameras are super
professional and you're amazing at
camerawork
maybe music you're halfway
you're halfway there oh
that may be music
we do a lot of research and we take a
lot of this
very seriously like the quality the
quality we do takes years
it's taken us a while to get here like
if we listen
or watch some of our older videos like
they can make us cringe because the
audio is so bad
and honestly like there are some things
where i know that we could get better at
this that or whatever we could move to
like 4k
12k 8k or whatever and all this like
whatever whatever but honestly like the
the main focus for us is efficiency
and i think when it comes to efficiency
there's not many people who can beat
when it comes to like producing content
we're professional youtubers that gets
lots they get
large amounts of views for like the size
you're at
with like very little time put in i mean
talking with other people who have been
on
um tv and movie shoots the amount of
time
that goes into that and the amount the
the sheer man hours
is huge and and you know the two of us
are just
cranking out content literally on five
channels
and it's just a lot now what we did is
we have
tuned our setup for that efficiency
you know i mean we could do like
scrolling
pan shots and have like timers where
like there's a time lapse and it goes
around on a track
but we realize that that's not really
what our content is about
and um we didn't really have i mean you
had a little bit of camera experience
with like a little bit of like um
hobby photography kind of um
and other than that we didn't really
have any experience
with the kind of stuff that we do now no
it's all it's all been learned just like
through youtube videos and there's a lot
of online research
so i'd say halfway there yeah okay
another assumption from bree tube i
assume that they don't like
doing crafts as much as they used to i
think that's to me
that's incorrect i like doing it more
yeah
i like doing it more i think the reason
i like doing it more
is when we first started doing things we
were much more tutorial based
and so we were we had to think like oh
are we explaining this the best way did
we get a shot that clearly shows that do
we need to be more elaborate
like the things we worried about were
more that and now
because we're not really doing tutorials
it's more just like hang out with us
while we do this project
it's made it a lot more fun well i think
that another thing maybe going back even
farther
for bree's question maybe she was saying
before we started the channel
whatsoever like when we were doing
crafts for the wedding
oh yeah and crafts just for like or like
even fixing the house i think that i
enjoy it a lot more
because at the end we have this like
glowing
center of satisfaction that just like
powers us in our like by having the
video
by having the video by like having the
time mean something
in multiple ways because i think that
like i don't know what discussion we
were having
but we just love efficiency
what was that discussion around do you
remember what that was i don't remember
we talked about efficiency a lot we
talked about
i think that we were just talking about
happiness or something and somehow
efficiency came up and efficiency is
just something that we
we love a lot and i think that there's
another side of things
along how are you tying in efficiency
we we are living our lives and our
hobbies that we enjoy
we're also getting paid for we're
enjoying it we're spending time together
which makes our time
we're layering the the time that we
spend in our days
is like hits multiple check boxes all at
once per minute
or something you know what i mean which
is why even though we we will often joke
like at the beginning of this podcast
hour like
seven days a week you know 12 hours a
day
um we we do kind of joke about that but
not
not in a like we want you guys to feel
bad for us it's
you know we joke about it because it
just is it is what it is yeah
we have chosen to do this and one reason
that
we do it is because like you said so
many things are layered it's not like
we're it's like when we're working we're
also hanging out
we're also playing video games or making
a craft
or you know even like editing like i
enjoy editing or like
you enjoy designing things like and of
course there's parts of parts of our job
that
are feel more like work but that
those parts are not the hour a day
seven days a week you know it's not that
all the time but i think that there's
another thing and
one one reason why we have five channels
why we have
mixed it up so much is because the
mixing it up
makes everything fresh again and the the
reason why we do like
you know resin crafts and then we react
to or then we like test out
life hacks and then we do like a crazy
underwater stream
that variety makes it all feel fresh all
the time
whereas i i do worry that if we were
doing the same thing every day like i
think we might get bored
as fast as we can like filming a video
and then editing it then filming a video
then editing it and it's like the same
types of videos i think that we would
burn out yeah i think so
and i feel like we would need breaks
yeah to like add more
like varied life in between but since
our life is varied
doing all of the things we do for work
we don't need to break as much
yeah i would say that's true yeah yeah
oh and i would also say just on the
doing like enjoying the crafts more now
than before i think a big part of it
is like getting to share things it does
make it even more enjoyable
yeah we have talked about that like
sharing things online is something we
enjoy
yeah also by the way i wonder if
anyone's that's watching the video
version of this has noticed
something different oh oh about
me about caitlyn well we'll answer we'll
answer what it is at the end of the
podcast
what if we forget we probably will
okay um here is an assumption from
kaylee i assume
you've tried like 30 different things
and none of them work so they didn't get
a video
i would say there have been a couple
things that we tried to do as projects
that didn't end up
becoming a video i can't even remember
any one
was we were going to do 3d printed
like copper 3d printed letterboard
letters this was a really long time ago
but you know those letter boards that
are on like pinterest and instagram they
say little cute messages
we were going to 3d print our own
letters and like emojis and stuff with
this copper filament
and we started that we just never
finished it we we just
we kind of it just got boring and i
think there's been some more
there's some that are like in progress
that yeah we have a pro
like i want to revisit the propane
cannon
but there's one that i can't mention
that is in progress
oh that one logistically complicated
logistically complicated yeah so there's
some things that are in progress that
aren't videos that like might be one day
it's very small the number of times
we've
started and stopped yeah like that's all
i can think of there's been a few times
where we've started researching for a
project
and then realize it's not right but the
times where we've actually started
filming and not finished it i can only
think of
two honestly two yeah that's all i can
think of there might be one or
so more but um maybe three yeah but
usually like
i think the thing especially about our
videos now is
like for most projects they don't have
to turn out
perfectly as we envisioned them for them
for it to be a good video now
most of them it does end up like pretty
close to what we wanted but that kind of
removes some of the pressure
um that might cause us to feel like we
have to abandon
a project like we'll just we'll just go
with it even if it's not going perfect
yeah rucifer assumes that you two would
want to build your own house or
completely renovate a fixer-upper
i i'm just going to answer for me
because we haven't touched on this
recently but i
would that's no for me so
i've changed on this slightly
because like back in our blogging days
when we were fixing up our house and
blogging about it i thought that would
be like
the coolest thing to do a fixer-upper it
was very in line with like the blogs i
was reading
and the show fixer-upper and like a lot
of the content that i was
consuming and it seemed cool
but what i have since realized
is i mean one if we did anything like
that we would of course be
documenting it i i think i would like a
little bit of that
um but i would not
there's a lot of like renovation stuff
that i just have no
interest in doing i have no interest in
like
like getting good enough at that i would
trust myself to do it on our house like
plumbing electrical
like foundation like
like the the basic bones and structure
i've no interest in doing that
you know i might be down to like turn a
wall
no i would knock down a wall i would
just the destruction part
i would do some of the building back up
with some health
with with help um
so i could see us doing some sort of
like hybrid maybe but
i think i think what i've realized
is like even though that stuff seems
very
exciting and glamorous isn't the right
word from the outside
but like the transformation is glamorous
yeah like the thought of
doing a lot of that work ourselves does
not sound like fun work and if we're
making a video about something
we need to be enjoying it otherwise it's
going to be a terrible video so
i think that this is my this is my
thought
if we found a house that was in the
exact right location
that was the right size that had
everything that we wanted somehow
magically
we'll just get that and then we would
use that efficiency because we like
efficiency to
just create more good videos you know um
but if there was a house that would have
good structure good bones and was
like a pretty like close fit
and well i'm not afraid of fixing it up
some but i'm not sure how much of that
we would be doing versus how much would
be getting help on that
yeah again it depends on if like the
work was fun or not
yeah you know nice all right so avid
reader has a
assumption i thought you were going to
read it
um avid reader says you or assumes that
you've been able to film videos
slash live stream even while having
disagreements privately
that is kind of true we do non-verbally
communicate
it's not disagreements but like caitlyn
will give me a warning if i'm like
going off on tangents too much or like
not really that okay well let's separate
live streaming and
videos oh yeah if we're filming a video
and there's something
we're not agreeing on we won't film it
until we've like talked about something
yeah totally
um just because like there's you know
we're we're in control of the filming
process we can just be like
we could just stop filming and chat
about like whatever it is that we might
be disagreeing about
like we had different ideas for like
what the intro would be
and we thought we were on the same page
but we were on the same page so we kind
of went in different directions
like we'll stop and we'll talk about it
we'll figure it out and then we'll start
filming again and that's the main place
where
we'll need to have discussions the intro
is so hard live streaming
there's not really disagreements isn't
the right
word there's not we don't really have
like disagreements while we're
live streaming or like like if there's a
disagreement we have beforehand
we would talk about it but there like
there have been a few times i
can't i'm trying to think of like a
specific situation
um but like where one of us will like
give the other person like a secret
squeeze like
oh we shouldn't talk about like it like
if we're like like be aware of what
you're doing
you know it's not like a disagreement
it's like a little hey heads up yeah
like oh we can't we're not supposed to
talk
about like like you're talking about
behind the scenes
sponsor stuff make sure you don't
mention the sponsor name because we
signed an nda and we can't say who the
sponsor's name is yeah you know little
like things like that so we'll give like
a little like like a little like
knee squeeze like be careful about the
direction you're going the coolest thing
though is we do have like
good non-verbal communication skills
like during conversations even just like
in real life with other people around
you know it's like
well we just like kind of know each
other's like wavelengths or something
like that
like back when we went to events yeah we
would often do that
oh my gosh yeah managing like you know
lots of things
like if we get separated yeah like in
the in the crowd
we can like find each other and like
signal yeah
that was good um so let's see uh
lucas says at first glance you look
dorky crazy and fun and you make a lot
of jokes but at second glance
you are hard-working independent people
that value your work greatly i think
that that kind of is
that that is an interesting thing
because we do try to kind of balance
those two aspects
yeah because we do work really hard
and i think that you're very intelligent
i think you're very intelligent oh thank
you
thank you handshake business handshake
but at the same time business partners
we are like
we are both of those things truly like
as part of our core identities i am
extremely corny and goofy
and fun-loving but we all are also
very hard-working and we've combined
both of those to make our youtube videos
because
yeah that just works for us and a lot of
the like
hard-working side might like at first
glance
seem like that's all the
behind-the-scenes stuff but like
a lot of the stuff that we've made like
think about like the
tense agree table or like the underwater
stream i know that video is not out yet
but
if you watch the live stream you got to
kind of see like a preview
of what the setup is like those things
aren't things that just come easy
you know and there's some videos that
like are pretty quick and easy
to put together and don't require a ton
of hard work like testing the life hacks
for example
um you know every now and then we were
able to find a
an easy project we could do but like a
lot of them do require a lot of work in
brainstorming and designing and
redesigning and
um sourcing of materials or coming up
with new com
new ways to use existing materials
because that's what makes it for
interesting videos hours and hours of
sponsor emails
oh my gosh days days days
days we're not gonna get into it because
everything is good
[Laughter]
you're very convincing very convincing
yeah i would say like that
we are both but at first glance we
probably
uh come off you probably see like the
goofy side
yeah you see the goofy side more than
the hard working side um just because
you know it's more in your face most of
the hard working side is honestly behind
the computer um and
that that that just isn't super
interesting
i have a good one i just like look at
this and i was like oh i just want to
see what you think
christopher um hefner assumes that
caitlyn holds back her frustration when
evan goes on a tangent when the camera's
rolling
so i would say that in the past
i i would be like
trying to edit your words in my head
and make sure like okay if you're going
on a tangent
is this a tangent that i can include and
if it's not a tangent then i can
include i need to bring you back to the
original thought
so that i can cut out the whole tangent
i would say these days
i've leaned more into just like let like
the tangent still just roll
the tangents and i'm like i'm like
either i cut it or i turn it into a
funny thing
and it doesn't really matter which one i
do so like it's fine either way you have
the robot voice difference
yeah i used to stress more about you not
finishing your sentences and i would
like prompt you
yeah um because i'm like i need you to
finish that thought for the edit and
sometimes i do get a little caught up in
my head
like when we're filming because i am
like editing it slightly and
that makes sense because you have to
make what we film work in the end you're
the one who's responsible for like
pulling all the loose little bits
together into one like
you know you pull all the threads into a
fabric or something like that you know
um so i know that that stress is on you
most of
my stress is like what do we do next how
is this going to work
like when are the supplies coming in et
cetera et cetera
um and i think that's divide and conquer
i wanted to i'll bring up christopher's
question because
christopher's question because i i do
think that you were more frustrated in
the past
and now it's almost like a bonus yeah or
something it just leads
it leads to good things more than bad
things yeah
and if it and if it ends up not being a
funny thing then i can
just cut it if i need to cut it or just
yeah i don't worry i've added text
transition
or something you know yeah i mean yeah
and then evan
then evan talked about technology for
five minutes straight and then i just
have like little bits of you and this
and this
and that and that and it fades and it
zooms you have more tricks up your
sleeves yeah i have more tricks
more editing like food ninja stars
yeah that is a good way to put it
because before i only had like a couple
techniques to get across what we were
trying to communicate
and so if the raw material didn't fit
into those techniques
then i'd have to like catch it in the
moment
so i would be thinking about like when
evan finishes his sentence
i'm gonna have to say like hey can we
say that one more time just in case
i think that i actually have also gotten
better about
making the flow of things be a little
bit smoother and it's mainly
podcasts and live streams that have
helped me with that honestly
yeah like all of our editing to help
yeah
all of our content has been like linked
and
like like that benefiting its mutual
partners around
yeah which i think is interesting brian
amont has an assumption that there is
stress involved
weighing what you would like to do
against whether it will trend
um i think
there there is some stress involved with
that
um because obviously you want your
videos
to do well there are some videos that we
just do
and we know they're not gonna do well
and that's okay so for example like the
first cooking video
we were like it was probably not going
to do super great it actually ended up
doing a lot better than we expected
um but we were okay with that and
there's some videos that we honestly
kind of do
just to like keep our maker makers
chomps strong i'm not sure that like is
it crazy is it chomped
chops i think it's chops chops
you know or something like that you know
i don't know you know what's interesting
in the
comments of our um video that just went
out the life hacks video because it's
titled like
makers test viral diy life hacks
yeah um there are people in the
in the comments that like weren't sure
why we use the word maker
oh like um
and it's interesting because like we
started in the maker community
which is kind of like this should we
define that maybe
maybe yeah um like we started there but
we've kind of
like our some of our audience is still
part of that community but some of our
audience
like is not part of that community yeah
and i don't know exactly where the split
is but it used to be like all makers
because we were doing tutorials like
you're not watching tutorials if you're
not making stuff
but so like like the maker term yeah so
i think
makers is a term that a group of people
have kind of settled on
to identify themselves as because
woodworker metal worker 3d printers 3d
printer
like crafter or craftsman crafts woman
or like like needlepointist or like what
you know whatever resin artists resin
artists like
that whole community kind of identi like
has been unifying to a certain degree
around the term maker because a lot of
these are getting mixed
too there are people who are woodworkers
metal workers they're people who are
resin artists and woodworkers they're
people who do crafts
and build a workbench you know i mean
like all of that's
mixing it seems more and more and maker
just seems to be the best
term for it yeah that kind of
encompasses
all of it so it's like if you make
things any types of things
you're a maker but it is a slightly like
newer it is a niche term term it's more
niche
like i first i think heard it used that
way with maker faire
yeah um which is so funny because
maker faire like make magazine wasn't
wasn't even that wasn't even that make
magazine was like
i like all about tech and technology it
wasn't about the maker movement
but it kind of got adopted by the fact
that yeah yeah yeah yeah and then they
adopted
yeah in turn and everything yeah
um so i think that going back to brian's
question though i assume that there is
some stress
involved weighing what you would like to
do against whether or not it will trend
it's not really trend even it's like
will it perform well for our channel
and honestly the thing that's so
interesting to me is the time we were
most
stressed about our videos performing
well is
when we were when our channel was
growing really well
when we had had like four good videos in
a row
and you don't want to break yourself the
more yeah you get like more pressure
the longer you have a good streak which
is weird
yeah and kind of like having like a
video that's like really like not good
like and then you can have another one
that's not as good that kind of breaks
the cycle
and it like frees you up to like say i'm
just kidding
i don't know yeah you're like kind of
more bummed out for a little bit like
man the past few have just like not been
great but then you're like
well just experiment because like it
might i do great anyway
i mean maybe that's just us that's just
how we approach it and everything
but um there is stress involved in
choosing
a good idea but once we know it's a good
idea and it's something that we're
excited about we just go for it yeah
um from sharp shooters i assume it was
evan's idea to start the channel
can you even remember that fargo because
i can't i
i can't actually it's a marvelous idea
to start selling products which is one
thing that
led us to the i kind of started the ball
rolling in general by quitting my job
and
starting down this this alternate path
um i don't know who brought up
youtube first i don't know either
i remember us having initial discussions
about it because we were like
there's not really too many couples out
there that
make things together it was almost like
at the same time
we were having a conversation that led
to us
saying that we want a youtube channel
and both of us were
were present in that conversation
yeah i don't feel like it was one person
presenting it to the other no it wasn't
one person presenting i think that like
we had just watched fixer upper or
something like that
yeah and this is like the height of
fixer upper yeah and then we just
started like
like searching what youtube channels
were out there together
and we realized that there's a gap
missing
and then we just are like are you
thinking what i'm thinking
yeah yes let's start a youtube channel
yeah so it's like almost like
concurrently there was no like yeah who
thought of it first it was like
literally a shared concept
yeah we used to have a lot of like like
when we were both working
our um office jobs we would have lunch
together almost every day
and there were lots of lunches where we
would just like brainstorm this stuff so
it was probably one of those lunches
um i think i remember it like
on our couch in our living room oh
really and we were just searching all
these youtube channels and stuff and we
were like
i do remember searching in the living
room what what what
should we should we do this i think
that's kind of how i remember it's so
fuzzy
all right so we have a question from or
an assumption from when grapes pop
i assume you two didn't realize you
would be so enjoyable to watch
when you started your channel what's
weird is i don't know
what we assumed i don't know it's like i
don't know what gave us the confidence
to say like
yeah we'll start a youtube channel and
people will come
i feel like we were overconfident and i
feel like if i knew as much as i knew
now
i might have more hesitation so it's
probably good that i didn't
yeah and in a way ignorance did help us
there yeah to a certain degree
i think like we already had the blog
and had a very very very small amount of
viewership there but we got good
feedback
there about people like like liking us
writing about the projects we did
together and so we were like if we just
turn that into video form like should be
pretty enjoyable um but
in our you know initial videos there's a
lot less of our own personalities
in the videos that's something that's
evolved a lot
over time yeah so like we
in the beginning we felt kind of weird
about putting our personalities more
into the video because it's like
as just like a tiny channel we were like
if people stumble upon us and they're
looking for a
tutorial on how to upgrade yeah fix
drywall
then if we're in there like
joking around like crazy they'll just be
like who are these people
and leave so we were really um
uh very conscious of not putting too
much of our personalities in in the
beginning
this is interesting we have an
assumption from malek
badarin sometimes you have fights and
end up having to make a video while
still upset with each other
and that there are quite a few videos up
on the channel where that has happened
that's almost more of a relationship
question that is
but uh i'm trying to think if there's
any videos that are up where we were
like
there's been videos where like like one
of us was frustrated at how
like a thing that went wrong with the
project and we kept going but
i don't think there's any where we were
upset at each other
because like we said if there's
something that we are upset about we'll
talk about it and figure it out
before we start filming again like we're
not gonna
yeah i mean they're i'm trying to think
i think the very first video where we
had a disconnect at the very beginning
where it was a big disconnect
was um
the wonder woman yeah the wonder woman
and but then we just like
stopped filming that entire day we just
hung out and chatted and figured out how
to approach things
and the reason there was a disconnect is
it was because
like like we said typically like i kind
of
keep straight in my head like what
scenes we're going to film how the edits
going to go together do we say
we need to say and evan kind of keeps
straight like what are what are the next
steps and this and that and for this
particular project
because it was one i was more interested
in doing
i took on the like research for it
but then like i wasn't properly
communicating that
like what we needed to do to you so you
didn't really know what to do and i was
also trying to
do all my typical like like
director producer brain type stuff i was
lost
yeah and you were super long it was just
the first time we had done that and we
were just like we just didn't know
like each of us had different
expectations of the other
because caitlyn was still like thinking
about things from a filming point of
view
um whereas normally i lead the project
and i do certain things so i was
assuming that she would do those things
and she was maybe assuming that i would
still be doing i wasn't
i know i wasn't assuming you would i was
just having a hard time playing both
roles playing both roles yeah
this is hard to play both roles at the
same time um but but with that like we
realized it pretty soon
like really and then yeah like really
soon into starting like i don't even
know if we had filmed
anything like i don't think any anything
where we were like not on the same page
is in the video
like my memory is that we realized we
were both kind of
off yeah and so we stopped filming we
like talked about it and figured out
what it was
that was like making us laugh and then
we were like okay we're good
we like know why we were getting
frustrated like everyone was feeling
lost i was feeling overwhelmed
we like figured stuff out and then we
filmed
and i remember the filming process was
really fun like playing with
the warblah and the thermoplastic and
all of that stuff that was just that was
just some good stuff
um oh no was it was it the tiara tiara
was yeah yes yes
yeah no not not the racers the tiara
yeah um
yeah and there have been other moments
where one of us has been upset
for one reason or another mostly
honestly it's me
and because like because like like
between the two of us we
get so rarely upset and that's all
resolved and all of that real quick
because we address it
but the thing that just gets frustrating
is like when the project goes wrong
and if you guys have been out there like
making a project you put so much time
into it
and then you accidentally spray acetone
all over your project and it ruins the
polishing that you've done
on your resin knives and you just it's
just upsetting
it's just upsetting especially like
valuing
efficiency and then like taking on three
knives instead of just one
and it all worked out in the end and
that video did well but like
oh there's just some things that just
upset you yeah
and you're just upset yeah and honestly
we just like i just keep on working we
just don't film for a while
yeah and then we film when we're like
good to go again yeah
exactly yeah i was gonna say even then
we don't no like if one of us
is genuinely frustrated like we wait
till we're at a better
place to start filming again because
like we're not good actors
no if if you've seen us upset in a video
it's because we're upset and if we're
happy it's because we're happy but
there's
there haven't been like almost any i
can't think of any moment at all
where it looks like we're happy but
we're not happy on the inside
i have been sick oh my gosh yeah yeah
i remember once we even acknowledged it
during the uh there was twice where i
was
i was sick when we were filming and
the the second time was when we made
this desk the rainbow resin
desk and i remember like i was having
flashbacks to the first time i was sick
and i was like i can't just pretend to
be normal so we just like acknowledged
it
yeah and then i felt a lot more freedom
to just be like
more energy in that moment and it was
fine was the other video the other video
was our christmas ornaments video
oh yeah oh that was that was it was
miserable for you we have a couple
it's the um one where we did three
different styles not the resin ones that
we did with
um make something as a collab but the
the three different style one
so it was like right before christmas we
were in a super huge rush because we're
working a bunch of projects
and we were working on christmas
presents for everybody and like
everything had to be done before
christmas and we were working on holiday
orders
because we still worked we still like
sold products to west elm at that point
there's so many things it was our first
um
like holiday rush for the products so
such a stressful time well just thinking
about it
and so like we we couldn't put off the
video
so i was like i'll just film even though
i'm sick and so if you guys
if you guys watched that video i was i
had a fever the whole time we were
filming it yeah that wasn't
that was good yeah but at the same time
we
we felt like we couldn't stop and we
really couldn't without breaking
commitments
yeah because we had sponsor commitments
the main lesson we learned is just like
don't commit that much yeah it took us
another like
um the king assumes that i feel like you
guys are extremely different
on camera i think we've addressed that
like many many times haven't we
yeah no we're not we're not really
different like no yeah
the main thing the camera misses is like
the times where just not much is going
on and we're just kind of like quietly
working on our desks
but morgan anne assumes that both of us
drink at least a pot of coffee to finish
your projects at night
no oh we just do not drink coffee
because then we can never fall asleep
yeah well i mean you mean at night yeah
we
we share one cup of coffee yeah no we
don't we don't
go crazy on the caffeine yeah we would
just never sleep we have a hard enough
time sleeping so
um um david dick assumes that you don't
like to re-watch your previous
previously published videos you know i
actually kind of do
i kind of do it's like a mixture of
like enjoyment and a hint of cringe
[Laughter]
past a certain point i mean past a
certain point i just kind of
i'm proud of them mm-hmm and i i i like
them
and like sometimes i'll go back to watch
maybe this is like
i don't know this is gonna sound
conceited or something maybe i shouldn't
say this but like
sometimes i'll go back to like watch a
video to see what product we used or to
like pull some bit of information from
it and i'll just like start watching it
like oh that's a good video
i stand by that the thing that's
craziest to me though is
how short our old videos are more than
anything
like more than the cringe i'm just i'm
just like
that's so short i know our videos used
to be like a few minutes long
like i remember we did the um when i was
editing that very first batch that we
released all the same time
one of the garage videos was like seven
minutes and i was like
is it too much is it too long there's
like a three minute video in there so
we have a two minute video two minute
video oh my gosh yeah
yeah that's crazy it is weird yeah but
we don't we don't dislike it it's like
like i said it's kind of fun there's a
little bit of cringiness
like you know i wish that like our audio
was better
in older videos yeah the audio does make
me cringe
that's the main thing that makes me
cringe it's not like us being awkward
it's like yeah it's
cringy but it's it's who we are so
whatever but like the audio makes me
cringe a little bit man there's there's
so many there's like
two more assumptions jada assumed evan
started the youtube channel
um stephen i assume that the channels
were evan's idea
that's interesting multiple time yeah
now the channels channel gaming channel
is definitely your idea
definitely my idea and i think evan and
katelyn too that was my idea
i don't remember the podcast i think the
podcast was a joint thing it was joined
yeah
because we were it was another like
shared vision it was around the time
where we started
both listening to podcasts
and it just seemed to make sense because
there are just certain things where this
is just the best format
like responding to y'all's assumptions
about us there's
you know this is this is you know
this you don't need to like necessarily
watch us for this even though i know
that a lot of you people
a lot of people do have this on the
background or have watched this in video
form
hi but like you know this is a nice
background
thing where a lot of our content isn't
as much background
so yeah it's just it's just it just is a
good
place to have it yeah from laura nicole
i assume you'll get tons of sponsor
offers but take very few oh my gosh
so we we have severely cut down the
amount of videos
we do there's a period where we were
doing like four to six per month and now
we do
like two a month and so
like by the nature of that the amount of
sponsorships we
accept has gone down significantly and
we have a couple long-term
sponsorships that are like recurring so
like we're
we're basically booked for the year even
if we weren't
i think there'd be still a lot we turned
down but in terms of the quantity i
think i'll divide it into two
three categories so there's the stuff
that doesn't even meet the threshold
that we just don't even remember that we
just don't even respond to so it's like
we get a
ton daily yeah
like like multiple a day on average
where that just like
just we could do a whole podcast on
if you guys sponsorship that let us know
in the comments well yeah i think
there's something interesting to
touch on just briefly a little teaser
and then there's the mid tier
where we either think about it for a
little bit but most of the time we just
or if it's like a really good fit for
one reason or another we'll maybe like
check to see if we can work something
out
and then there's this stuff that like is
worth considering
and even in the stuff that's like really
worth considering like
companies that everyone recognized
monetary amounts that are very appealing
we still turn down those more than we
say yes
yes there's more of them that we say no
to that than what that we say yes to
and we've told some of our families
about like
the the general scope of things because
there are ndas that we can't
reach but like like some of the
companies that we've said no to
and they're like what but then they're
also like
you guys should not work so much but
what how could you say no to that
company
we're like we don't have time i know our
parents watch this hi guys love you
it's just it's just it's just funny to
us yeah but yeah
we do say
no to so many sponsors because of a ton
of reasons yeah we could just do a whole
we could do a whole podcast about
sponsors i think that would be
interesting but we also have to be very
generic about certain things
yeah we wouldn't be saying specifics
just because of
like ndas and relationships with
specimens we can't
share numbers we can't share names yeah
but we could talk generically
we can talk generically yeah that's
interesting um
eth orlan assumes that there's an
exorbitant amount of cleanup work that
goes on behind the scenes
of your projects oh yeah
oh yes some projects obviously much
worse than others
um we did when did we do our live stream
underwater
um the stream itself was like a week and
a half ago
week and a half ago we just cleaned up
that mess two days ago one day ago two
days ago
yeah i mean you guys saw the photo of
our living room on socials and that was
just the living room that wasn't even
the workshop
there's there's constant it's constant
it's constant it's just like a rotating
mess yeah it's just a rotating mess so
some projects are worse than others
um oh my gosh summer bell assumes that
um if
we ever did a collab with jenna and
julian it would be too much
aries energy disaster no it would be
balanced
should be balanced because caitlyn is
also
i am a virgo
yeah i would i would balance now of
course they're not really filming much
videos right now and
you know um and they also don't know us
they don't know us like it would be it
would be cool to meet more youtubers and
get to know more youtubers
mainly just so we can like share these
experiences that like
you know it's hard to talk about like
these bonding experiences that youtubers
go through
yeah you know it's like whenever like i
think one of our favorite things about
going to
um places where there are other content
creators
is sharing all these stories and like
all like bonding over
shared experiences i think that's just
yeah
it's just it's that's our favorite part
of going to it's our favorite part yeah
yeah all right do you have one okay yeah
um this
this person asked two questions so we
can answer them separately
um well one is very similar i assume you
want to do a co-lab with simply
illogical that would be fun
we watch a lot of simply um the other
one is oh this is from megan
did i say that i don't know um i think
you guys get nervous when you film in a
store like when you go to lowe's to pick
out materials for project
yeah i think in terms of co-labs like we
we do
really want to do more collabs in the
future but we want to get to know people
first yeah so so it'd be hard to do more
collabs until we
like went to events again and also we
can't do them now because
we we can't yeah events aren't happening
and
traveling for co-ops yeah that's not
happening so um in terms of getting
nervous when you film in a store
we used to more yeah and
more cool with it now yeah so for the
example you gave
lowe's they were a sponsor of ours for a
pretty long time
um and we were there a lot
um so i was less nervous about filming
there because we like
got to know a lot of the employees there
because we were there all the time and
they knew
that we did youtube videos so like the
filming was kind of normal
is there or something yeah we're not
like trying to yeah exactly we're not
like
like doing a like in-store prank i did
get nervous filming in
walmart when we were picking up our ugly
christmas sweaters
because walmart is a place where a lot
of youtubers like go and do shady stuff
and i was like oh no if we're filming
here they're going to think we're doing
shady stuff
it's like we're just filming us picking
up like christmas sweaters and trying on
different christmas lights we're not
doing like a prank or anything i didn't
get a little bit nervous we were like
hiding the camera a little bit
trying to be very discreet which made us
probably look more scared
um so yeah kind of depends on the place
yeah um
but it was interesting at lowe's the the
managers and the people there got to
know us and um
you know they knew that we had the
blessing from those corporates
yes but when we felt at the other store
we actually did get approached oh yeah
and they're like are you filming here or
do you have
the right permission and we're like
actually we
we actually do yeah that's what we went
to
we have been requested to film in here
um that was kind of fun yeah um
everyday live assumes that there are
dirty jokes comments you have to edit
out sometimes
i believe in some of the ones that
aren't too bad
um there's a there's an interesting
assumption about how we present
our jobs okay the wiz dad um assumes
that family get
togethers can be awkward when the
question is asked what do you guys do
and instead of answering
we own a digital media company we say we
make youtube videos and play games on
twitch
it really depends on the circumstances
we've answered both ways
yeah for family all of our family knows
what we do
yeah um like we're both pretty close to
our families and
even like extended families because we
both have big family reunions
every other year um so they all they all
know what we do
um i there are some times
um like when we were picking up the
scuba gear for our underwater
stream um we're making an
advertisement yeah they were like so
what are you what are you guys doing
um and like because he had asked like
where we're diving and we're like oh
we'll just be in a pool
and he was like oh what are you what are
you doing and so we're like
we're filming an advertisement and you
know what
we were being perfectly truthful that's
true
that is true we are a production company
in a way yeah small we have sponsors and
we film advertisements for those
sponsors
so you know but sometimes you just don't
feel like explaining
[Laughter]
this is easier it's easier um
taiyuki vlogs assumes that we receive a
lot more injuries from your projects
than you show in your videos
you receive a lot of minor injuries
nothing too major but like your hands
have gotten pretty scratched up
trying to remember like what
honestly most of the times i've injured
myself it's been in between
projects like i have cut myself with a
knife before
um i have dropped a
i was moving a lamp from one room to
another after we had bought it and i
dropped it
right it was a glass it was a glancing
blow
against our countertop very light tap
and a shard hit my foot
but honestly i've been more injured in
my everyday life
than in making projects maybe it's
because like
when we're making projects like even
though we do come off as
goofy and i'm sure sometimes we have
like forgotten
to do everything perfectly but we are
more conscious
of like ooh we should put on safety
glasses for this or like
ooh gotta gotta do this or i think that
like we have done like unintentionally
like
well there's one video we did something
dangerous we were using a table saw
wrong and we privated that video so that
we weren't like perpetuating
an unsafe practice but in general i i
think that
both of our work environments promoted
safety a lot
in our past jobs like because we worked
normal corporate jobs and i worked
in engineering in new product
development in product
testing so i worked with
machines spinning at 10 000 rpm and high
pressures and
like like pressures that are like way
beyond anything would ever see in our
house
like 10 000 psi pressures and stuff
um so working in that environment
really prepared me to like my work
didn't really have any
really safety safety but there's still a
culture of safety
not really okay not in the branding team
not with the graphic designers yeah okay
well then maybe
that's something that's on my mind a lot
and you know i've picked up
habits from you yeah i i had to get like
i feel bad
i feel like like weird like scolding
caitlyn but like when she was cutting
with knives towards her
i'm like dude you shouldn't do that and
she's like i can do what i want
i didn't say that i said i was going
slowly
but it was bad it was that i should have
done it and then and then you said later
on
you're like i'm glad you called me
but like but we do we do
take safety like
safety is very important to us knock on
wood we haven't had anything you only
get one body part
of all your body parts well i guess you
get some of
multiples but yeah the limited number of
body parts
to injure and you have to be very
careful with them yeah
luckily nothing nothing too too bad or
extreme
um well i think actually caitlin this
this we i think we might need to wrap up
we still have like we still have so much
more
like specific to streaming specific
projects
oh my gosh and we're an hour into this
oh my gosh
you guys we're never gonna get through
all these assumptions okay these are
these are
so much fun they're really should we
take a break to do another type of
podcast okay you guys let us know in the
comments do you want more assumptions
or do you want a different format
because we've done three assumptions
podcasts
are really fun for us maybe in the
youtube video we'll do a poll
in the card oh we could do that are you
going to remember to do that i'm not
going to remember
if if if not i'll do it on a twitter
comment and a
twitter post and if i don't do that
remind us remind us
because we might forget oh but this this
has been really fun but you know
it's time to move on to thing of the
week
my thing of the week is this is gonna
sound lame
and i often do lame things but the the
lame things that are very cool too
yeah my thing of the week are chord
organizers
but it's specific type a specific type
you just ordered like another hundred
pack
i i've gone through at least 200 of
these chord organizers
and none of them have failed me ever and
what that means is i have 200 quarter
organizers on
200 chords do we have 200 chords
probably oh my gosh that's a lot of
chords
that's a lot of chords or or maybe
they're just round and like various
gizmos we've made or whatever but like
do you want to describe what kind of
chord organization so
it's it's uh they're thin they lock upon
themselves
and you can attach them to chords really
easily but they're just they're like
bundling chords or organizing chords or
strapping things down
i'll i'll i'll say it because you left
out anything they're velcro so it's like
vel like a velcro strip with a loop on
the end
so you can loop it through itself across
one corner
and then wrap it and you can combine
them to make them longer
so if you have like a big thing you need
to combine you can just add them
together
and then but they're they're they're
they're so versatile
they're so versatile they're just like
all over
all of our desks in our house we'll have
a link to them as usual in the
description yes my thing of the week
which i mean a lot of people have been
talking about this
lately because it's on netflix right now
but um avatar the last airbender it's so
good
that's just what we need times you know
we're on season three which is the last
season
i'm very sad we're like halfway through
the last season um but it's been
really good caitlin you know what what
i can't say much about it but there is
a kind of sequel some people like it
some people don't like it
we'll see oh man okay we'll consider it
we'll consider it um but yeah it's it's
really good it's on uh
netflix right now and it's an older show
but yeah i like it's so strange i
actually watched
three and a half seasons i somehow
didn't finish it and i think it's just
because like i was traveling abroad and
i didn't have
all of them downloaded and i just
got busy and never finished yeah it was
too long
since i'd last watched it and i knew i'd
have to watch the whole thing over again
so thank you for like being the reason
we can like revisit this
wonderful series it's also so
interesting watching the art style
evolve and mm-hmm
well it's interesting because we started
we tried to start it up the two of us
like years ago years ago you're like oh
this is a good anime like i think you'll
like this one
and we watched maybe like four episodes
and i remember thinking like this is a
slow start
it's a little bit of a slow start but
like oh it goes
and it's just so wholesome and cute yes
it is i like it yeah
i think i think the thing at the
beginning is you were worried it was too
just wholesome to just you two just
just a kid's show yeah because it has
that vibe a little bit at the beginning
yeah it doesn't like go too deep in the
beginning into
like the characters or the back story
um and it seems kind of more like
episodic
yeah and then especially in the
beginning but like
the story really builds over the seasons
and like you know some parts like get
kind of dark
which i like um
of course it's all there's lots of
wholesomeness yeah it's a good show it's
a good show it's a good show
um alrighty guys thanks so much for
joining us for another um evan and
katelyn podcast i know we've been doing
a lot of assumptions again we'll have a
poll somewhere
um we actually have a very interesting
card game
that i want to try we might do that next
maybe we'll do like yeah we can do
another assumptions we can do the card
game or we can do
the thing on sponsors and the card game
is a kind of like
questions that we ask each other based
cards so it'll lead to a lot of
discussions
it's not just like a game game i'm not
going to say it's dangerous but like oh
y'all kind of dangerous
oh y'all the questions that it asks are
like the types of questions that like
you're there
i'd feel weird asking anyone but caitlyn
these questions
in a way like like there's there's
different levels there's questions for
strangers questions for friends
questions for your relationship
questions for like your serious
relationship there's all like different
categories but even like even like the
questions for your friends i would have
a hard time asking
asking friends that fence that because
it's like it's so deep
personal questions oh man and some of it
i'm not even sure we've discussed them i
know these questions so
it might be a very interesting podcast
i'm kind of looking forward to it
um alrighty guys well thanks so much for
joining i'm sorry that was a little bit
of a tangent
and um again we really appreciate all of
the reviews y'all leave us
um on the podcast the apple podcast
store or whatever wherever you can leave
reviews
reading those just like makes us happy
and it's a nice positive boost for our
days
and plus we just got to keep the ongoing
prank of getting the evident caitlyn
podcast high enough
up in the charts that people will
download it not knowing what it is
and then they're very confused because i
don't know who we are so you know we
just got to keep on pranking them
see you next time bye